the Joe Rogan experience I've been
involved in the sport in one way or
another professionally since 1997 you
know that's when I first started working
for the UFC so it's been it's a long
[ __ ] time man you know that's a long
[ __ ] time I keep hearing rumors that
Dana White is going to become a boxing
promoter I've heard for like five years
he has yeah they are yeah they're
working on some [ __ ] I can't really tell
you much but they're definitely working
on some [ __ ] yeah they they put together
the Conor McGregor and Floyd made with a
junior fight of course with tme with
Floyd's company today ope rather what is
it called machines
yeah TMT the money that's what his
promotion team is called right TMT
Mayweather promotions crew yeah so he
and they did this sort of CO promotion
for that big fight and then they're
working on some other thing with Floyd
where Floyd wants to get involved with
them to promote something else it might
involved MMA fighters might involve
boxers and they've actively talked to a
bunch of other boxers and they're trying
to put some stuff together but yeah they
Zuffa boxing is a real thing they want a
UFC wants to put together some boxing
matches and maybe even some crossover
fight I just wonder how that works
because the the UFC model just won't
exists in the boxing world like you
can't you won't have enough control you
don't have to you just have to schedule
a couple big fights I mean they're not
gonna do it like they do the UFC where
they do a fight like the UFC literally
is a fight every week yeah right now
like for the next five weeks there's a
fight every weekend and people are
hitting pay-per-view dollars well it's
the SPM Plus or ESPN and sometimes paper
oh great should I get to watch these UFC
fights for like $5.99 a month nope ya
know
still it's totally 65 bucks yeah I
bought it on my TV this morning I
watched again when I was lifting this
morning and I had to pay 65 bucks you
know but it's um it's a weird thing
right like you can't really do it where
it's just $5.99 don't have pay-per-view
the big fights won't be big fights you
know they want how does a zone have it
do you have to pay I know you don't
that's their whole thing Oh Tyson Fury
and Dante that's gonna be on the zone no
no Tyson Fury and Dante I think is a
simulcast between Fox
if simulcast is the right word and ESP
in other words gonna have their own
separate paper views or you can watch
whichever production you like which is
gonna be something like yeah you know
nice the commentators see then it
becomes the commentators it depends and
we're you tuned in if you go to ESPN
you'll hear their people they got their
own any of their own broadcast I don't
they use Max Kellerman I am so confused
I loved his boxing commentary and he
doesn't comment on live fights anymore I
think that's got to be his own choice I
mean I can't imagine that they don't
want coffee [ __ ] why he not want to do
that he was so good at it oh I'd reward
is also one of my favorite guys
[Applause]